This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ty Winn was living in Virginia when he heard some news. Halfway around the world in Australia, people on social media were saying awful things about his parents. So I'm sitting there with the computer just reading through all these horrible comments, you know, you stupid, ephanagians and racially-laced comments about boycotting their shop. Ties parents owned a takeaway fast food shop near Brisbane.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。泰·温恩当时住在弗吉尼亚州，当时他听到了一些消息。在地球另一端的澳大利亚，社交媒体上的人们正在对他的父母说一些难听的话。所以当时我坐在电脑前，看着这些可怕的评论，你知道的，比如你们这些愚蠢的“ephanagians”（发音不准的粗口），还有带有种族色彩的呼吁抵制他们店铺的评论。泰的父母在布里斯班附近经营一家外卖快餐店。
The outcry on social media had grown out of what Ties says was a misunderstanding with a customer. Some out one of the largest Australian publications picked up on the story and it just created this absolute storm of negativity on social media. These dirt bags need to be named and shamed. Their business page on Google just got bombed with all of these negative reviews. They are self-absorbed snobbs with no respect. And it just, it caught it. It went viral.
社交媒体上的强烈抗议源于泰所说的一次与顾客的误解。澳大利亚最大的出版物之一报道了这个故事，这在社交媒体上引发了一场绝对的负面风暴。这些垃圾需要被点名羞辱。他们在谷歌上的商业页面被所有这些负面评论轰炸。他们是自以为是的势利小人，毫无尊严可言。这简直，它被捕获了。它病毒式传播了。
Feeling sick with anger and worry, Ty called his mom. He expected she was going to be devastated. And she responded, no. Things are fine really, I saw the article in the newspaper but really wasn't able to understand all of it. Ties parents were not native English speakers. They were also not on social media. They didn't know what was happening online. They just kept running their business as they always did. I think of that saying ignorance is bliss and usually that's used in a derogative sense
泰感到一阵恶心，既愤怒又担心，于是给妈妈打了电话。他以为妈妈会崩溃。而妈妈的回答是，没有。事情其实挺好的，我在报纸上看到了那篇文章，但实际上并不是很能理解全部内容。泰的父母母语不是英语。他们也不玩社交媒体。他们不知道网上发生了什么。他们只是像往常一样继续经营着他们的生意。我想起那句俗语“无知是福”，通常这是带贬义的
but I think it can be applied in a positive sense having seen what my parents have gone through that ignorance is bliss in the sense that it enabled them to really move forward in a way that knowledge would have held them back. TIE realized that there were other times ignorance had helped us parents. They had fled Vietnam as refugees without fully exploring all the wadifs. I think have they been fully aware of the number of folks who died trying to escape the country? I think more likely than not would have stayed in Vietnam. Being able to clearly see what's happening around us can save our lives, keep us from danger, help us make smart decisions.
但我认为它也可以从积极的意义来应用，在看到我的父母所经历的一切之后，这种无知是福，因为它使他们能够真正向前迈进，而如果拥有这些知识反而会拖累他们。泰意识到，还有其他时候无知曾帮助过他们的父母。他们作为难民逃离越南，并没有完全探索所有的“如果”。我想，如果他们完全意识到有多少人为了逃离这个国家而死？我想他们多半会留在越南。能够清楚地看到我们周围发生的事情可以挽救我们的生命，让我们远离危险，帮助我们做出明智的决定。
But knowledge, especially knowledge of how others perceive us, can also sometimes hold us back and keep us from achieving our potential. The paradox of knowledge this week on Hidden Brain. I saw this thing bouncing and I just, I was just enamored with the way it looked, with the way it made me feel. And ever since then, you know, my hand was connected to the basketball. Basketball felt like an extension of herself. And in elementary school, Medina got super excited when she found out that the school was going to have a girl's basketball team. This is a really exciting event for us.
但知识，尤其是关于别人如何看待我们的知识，有时也会阻碍我们，让我们无法发挥出我们的潜力。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨“知识的悖论”。我看到这个东西在弹跳，我只是，我只是迷恋它的外观，它带给我的感觉。从那以后，你知道的，我的手就和篮球连在了一起。篮球感觉就像是她身体的延伸。在小学时，梅迪纳发现学校要成立一个女子篮球队时，她兴奋极了。对我们来说，这是一个非常令人兴奋的活动。
Finally, we have a place to play as girls. And I talked to my teacher that morning and she just brushed it away. Medina could have internalized her teacher's attitude, but she shrugged it off. She told herself, if the teacher doesn't get it, that's her loss. Her feelings about basketball were unchanged and Medina made the team. Soon, local newspapers were taking notice of her team's success. But some years later, Medina encountered another challenge to her love for the sport. She was around 12 and her team got a new coach.
终于，我们作为女生有了可以打球的地方了。那天早上我和老师谈过，但她只是把这事敷衍了过去。梅迪纳本可以内化老师的态度，但她耸耸肩把它抛在了脑后。她告诉自己，如果老师不明白，那是她的损失。她对篮球的感情没有变，梅迪纳成功入选了球队。不久，当地报纸开始注意到她球队的成功。但几年后，梅迪纳对这项运动的热爱遇到了另一个挑战。她大约12岁，球队换了个新教练。
She was a college player from the local university and she was also a white woman. None of us thought anything about that. We were just 12 year old kids, super excited to just learn how to be good players. And the first thing she said when she saw me was, it looks like your finger was stuck in a electrical outlet, the way your hair looks. Medina, who was black, was stunned. What did her hair have to do with basketball? Everyone kind of chuckled,
她是当地大学的大学球员，也是个白人女性。我们谁也没把这当回事。我们只是12岁的小孩，超级兴奋地只想学习如何成为优秀的球员。她看到我时说的第一句话是，你这头发看起来就像插头触电了一样。梅迪纳是个黑人，她惊呆了。她的头发跟篮球有什么关系？大家都有些轻笑，
and I didn't know what a microaggression was. The only thing I knew was that it hurt, and I didn't laugh. I didn't know what a microaggression was. The only thing I knew was that it hurt and I didn't laugh. I didn't give in to it. And soon after I lost my starting position and I learned that I had to be way better than everyone else in order to, you know, earn my spot. If Medina had been able to understand the coach's comments at the time, she might have told herself, this is discrimination. The hell with this coach and the hell with basketball. But she didn't do that.
我当时不知道什么是微侵犯。我唯一知道的是这很伤人，而且我没有笑。我不知道什么是微侵犯。我唯一知道的是这很伤人，而且我没有笑。我没有向它屈服。不久之后，我失去了首发位置，我明白了，为了赢得我的一席之地，我必须比其他所有人都要优秀得多。如果当时的梅迪纳能够理解教练的评论，她可能会告诉自己，这就是歧视。见鬼去吧这个教练，见鬼去吧篮球。但她没有这么做。
She was so passionate, so naively passionate that the obstacles only served as fuel. If she had to be twice as good as the next player to want a spot on the team, then she would be twice as good. She practiced so hard and got so skilled, it became impossible to cut her. I loved basketball. I had a passion for it. I wanted to be the best player in the world. It was innocent. Yeah, these things happen. Yeah, these people are unfair, but I love it. And that just helps me get better, so everything is perfect. Medina and her team often traveled around the region to compete. Sometimes, before one of these road trips, Medina's mother would remind her of what it meant to be a young black girl in mostly white, rural or higher. My mom would say, Medina, be careful.
她是如此充满激情，如此天真地充满激情，以至于这些障碍仅仅成了燃料。如果她必须比下一个球员优秀两倍才能赢得球队的一席之地，那她就会优秀两倍。她刻苦训练，技术变得如此高超，以至于不可能把她刷掉。我热爱篮球。我对此充满激情。我想成为世界上最好的球员。这很纯真。是的，这些事情发生了。是的，这些人很不公平，但我热爱它。这只会帮我变得更好，所以一切都很完美。梅迪纳和她的球队经常去该地区各地参加比赛。有时，在这些客场之旅之前，梅迪纳的母亲会提醒她，作为一个生活在多白人、乡村或更高地区的年轻黑人女孩意味着什么。我妈妈会说，梅迪纳，小心点。
You're traveling to these rural areas. There aren't going to be a lot of black people. The people in these areas don't come in contact with a lot of black people. Don't go anywhere by yourself. Just be mindful of the environment that you're in. Young Medina rolled her eyes. Couldn't her mom see that these road games were about something far more important than race? They were about basketball.
你要去这些农村地区。那里不会有很多黑人。这些地区的人们接触不到很多黑人。不要独自去任何地方。只需注意你所处的环境。年轻的梅迪纳翻了个白眼。难道她妈妈看不出这些客场比赛比种族重要得多吗？它们是关于篮球的。
You know, as a 12-year-old kid, I'm thinking, nobody's thinking about these other things. We're just here to win we're going to beat them by 10 points and I would say ma you know everything's going to be fine you know it's more excited about these new shoes that I have and I was completely oblivious completely oblivious. Medina noticed that when she played road games in these small towns, people sometimes reacted strangely to her. When I would go into the bathrooms and, you know, people would stop what they were doing, look at me.
你知道，作为一个12岁的小孩，我想的是，没有人会去想这些别的事情。我们来这里就是为了赢，我们要赢他们10分，我会说，妈，你知道一切都会好起来的，你知道的，我更兴奋的是我这双新鞋，我完全懵懂无知，完全懵懂无知。梅迪纳注意到，当她在这些小镇打客场比赛时，人们有时对她的反应很奇怪。当我走进洗手间时，你知道的，人们会停下手头的事，看着我。
Into the stall, come out of the stall. They wouldn't flat out come out and call me a name, but... But Medina knew that something was going through their heads. In her 12-year-old sport-subst mind, she thought she knew what it was. These strangers were petrified about her basketball skills. They knew she was about to destroy that team on the court. I almost felt as though that was a good thing. You know, I mean, you're head. You're thinking about me. You should be studying for the game right now, and instead, you're preoccupied with what
进隔间，出隔间。他们不会直截了当地出来叫我外号，但是……但梅迪纳知道有些东西在他们脑子里转悠。在她12岁具有运动潜质的大脑中，她以为她知道那是什么。这些陌生人对她的球技感到惊恐。他们知道她准备在球场上摧毁那支球队。我几乎觉得这是一件好事。你知道的，我的意思是，你在想。你在想着我。你现在应该在为比赛做准备，而相反，你在全神贯注于我
I'm doing. So, yay, that's awesome. When they stepped on the court, Medina felt vindicated. It fueled my competition, my competitive spirit, and I mean doused gasoline directly onto it. I was on fire to just be the best. Uncontested, I wanted it to look like child's play. Mandita became good enough to get recruited to the University of Cincinnati. It was everything she imagined it would be. It was just an amazing sisterhood, from amazing coaches to a university that really stood
在做什么。所以，耶，这太棒了。当他们踏上球场时，梅迪纳感到自己被证明是正确的。它点燃了我的竞争心，我的竞争精神，我的意思是直接往上面浇了汽油。我斗志昂扬，只想成为最好的。无可争议，我想让它看起来像小孩子的游戏。曼迪塔表现足够优秀，得以被辛辛那提大学招募。这和她想象的一样。这是一个令人惊叹的姐妹会，从出色的教练到真正支持他们田径事业的大学。此外，球队很有天赋。他们赢了很多比赛。其中一名球员，安布尔·斯科奇，后来在WNBA执教。仅在那支球队中，教练就是名人堂篮球运动员。多丽丝·斯科特是名人堂篮球运动员。我是名人堂篮球运动员。没错。
behind their athletics. Plus, the team had talent. They won a lot of games. One of the players, Amber Scotch, she went on to coach in the WNBA. On that team alone, the coach is a Hall of Fame basketball player. Doris Scott is a Hall of Fame basketball player. I'm a Hall of Fame basketball player. That's right.
这里需要注意上下文。
Medina Slase is in her university's basketball hall of fame. She was that good. I played shooting guard and I ended my career the second all-time leading score at the university. I was the first woman to be drafted from the university into the WNBA. She was drafted by the Detroit Shock. Detroit Shock! We got one team, one goal.
梅迪纳·斯莱斯入选了她大学的篮球名人堂。她就是那么优秀。我打得分后卫，并以大学历史第二得分手的身份结束了我的职业生涯。我是第一个从该大学被选秀进入WNBA的女性。她被底特律震动队选中。底特律震动队！我们只有一个团队，一个目标。
What we got through this year? Bring it! So I packed up all my stuff and started my adult life. 35 seconds to play. Orlando's lead is 13, Zach Illusion, I on the right. Medina's childhood dream wasn't a dream any longer. She lost the basketball to Medina Slase. Slase with a crossover gets towards the left baseline.
我们今年是怎么度过的？来吧！所以我收拾好所有的东西，开始了我的成人生活。比赛还剩35秒。奥兰多的领先优势是13分，扎克·幻觉，我在右边。梅迪纳的童年梦想不再是梦想。她把球传给了梅迪纳·斯莱斯。斯莱斯通过一个变向突破到了左侧底线。
She hit the calm, a legitimate basketball star. Madina Slase hit the free throw line for the first time in her pro career. First free throw is good. Slase, a 77% free thrower at the University of Cincinnati. Second one is new. Slice for the near-steel on the far side. That's what she really brings in cold-club and great defensive attention.
她命中了那个冷静的进球，一个真正的篮球明星。马迪娜·斯莱斯在她职业生涯中首次站上罚球线。第一罚命中。斯莱斯，在辛辛那提大学时罚球命中率为77%。第二个没进。斯莱斯在远端完成了一次近距离抢断。这正是她真正带来的冷静以及出色的防守专注度。
Hawking, he should forward far-side rascals. Let's get past it with the near-side. Many people who love a sport as much as Medina would find it hard to turn to something else. But after the terrorist attacks of September 11, 2001, she enlisted in the military and rose through the ranks. Over the years, as she gained more professional experience and worked with more and more people, she started to see the world in a different light.
鹰眼，他应该传球到远侧的后卫。让我们从近侧突破过去。许多像梅迪纳一样热爱这项运动的人会发现很难转向其他事情。但在2001年9月11日的恐怖袭击之后，她参军并不断晋升。多年来，随着她获得更多专业经验并与越来越多的人共事，她开始以不同的眼光看待这个世界。
She thought back to pivotal moments from her childhood, moments like those awkward interactions in the bathroom during travel basketball games. Those interactions were no longer easy to brush off. These people didn't like me when I was a kid. These people weren't just afraid that I was much better than the competition. It was because I was black. It was probably because I was the only black person that this person has seen in their entire life. These people saw me as nothing.
她回想起童年的关键时刻，比如在旅游篮球比赛中洗手间里那些尴尬的互动。那些互动不再那么容易被忽视了。这些人自我还是个孩子的时候就不喜欢我。这些人不仅仅是害怕我比竞争对手好得多。这是因为我是黑人。这很可能因为我是这个人一生中见过的唯一的黑人。这些人认为我什么都不是。
Medina began to wonder how much of her life had been touched by people who saw her as inferior. And then she asked herself a disturbing question. Had her childhood naivete been a good thing or a bad thing? There are times where I feel as though naivete kept me safe. There are also times where I felt as though I was extremely vulnerable as a result. As a child, Medina's innocence provided her endless joy in basketball. Just as Tywin's parents could focus on their shop because they didn't know about the social media controversy, Medina was spared the knowledge that others saw her as inferior. But her naivete also meant she was unprepared when discrimination reared its head.
梅迪纳开始怀疑她的生活中到底有多少部分被那些视她为劣等人的人触碰过。然后她问了自己一个令人不安的问题。她童年的天真是一件好事还是一件坏事？有时我觉得天真保护了我的安全。但有时我也觉得因此我变得极其脆弱。在童年时期，梅迪纳的天真为她带来了无尽的篮球乐趣。正如泰·温恩的父母可以专注于他们的店铺，因为他们不知道社交媒体上的争议，梅迪纳也免于得知别人视她为劣等人。但她的天真也意味着当歧视抬头时，她毫无准备。
Medina has asked herself whether she would have stuck with basketball if she had been less naive, if she had recognized discrimination for what it was, as prejudice. Would she have stayed on a middle school team if she had really understood her coach's comment about her hair, would she have stopped playing in regional tournaments if she understood why strangers stared at her as if she was from another planet, and if she had quit those foundational opportunities, would she have made it to her university's Hall of Fame, the WNBA? I don't know if knowing would have hindered my future progression or if it would have propelled it. But I know for certain that I would not have been operating from a place of passion
梅迪纳曾问过自己，如果她当初不那么天真，如果她把歧视认作歧视、视之为偏见，她还会坚持打篮球吗？如果她真的理解了教练对她头发的评论，她还会留在中学球队吗？如果她明白为什么陌生人会像看外星人一样盯着她，她还会继续参加地区锦标赛吗？如果她放弃了那些基础的机会，她还能进入大学名人堂、进入WNBA吗？我不知道知道真相是会阻碍我未来的发展还是会推动它。但我可以肯定的是，我将不会怀揣着对篮球的热情
with basketball or just energy, it would have been a place of vengeance. Medina reflected back to her upbringing. She realized her mom's way of dealing with prejudice was to overcome disadvantage by simply ignoring it. I believe that she was trying to prepare me for experiences that she knew would occur as a black woman living in society. I believe that she wanted to set accountability very early and even though she knew that the chips would be stacked against me, or that I would have to work multiple times harder than my peers, I also feel as though she prescribed
或者纯粹的能量去行事，那将会是一个复仇的地方。梅迪纳回想起她的成长经历。她意识到她妈妈处理偏见的方式是通过简单地忽视它来克服劣势。我相信她是在为我做准备，去面对她知道作为一个生活在社会中的黑人女性将会经历的事情。我相信她想尽早建立责任感，尽管她知道命运对我不利，或者我必须付出比同龄人多好几倍的努力，但我也觉得她笃信
to the notion that if it was meant to be, I had to seize the reins of this thing and put the most the best effort that I had possible into it. I couldn't blame the referees. I had to say I have to be that much better so that the referees don't even come into play. I couldn't blame my teachers. I had to be that much better. It had to be irrefutable. Would she have been better off if her mother had pursued a different philosophy? If she had sat Medina down and explained more about what might lie ahead? There's no doubt about it. I was completely in the dark.
这样一个观念：如果这是注定要发生的，我就必须抓住这件事的缰绳，倾注我可能拥有的最大、最好的努力。我不能责怪裁判。我必须说，我必须表现得更好，好到裁判甚至没有发挥作用的余地。我不能责怪我的老师。我必须表现得更好。这必须是无可辩驳的。如果她的母亲奉行不同的哲学，她会过得更好吗？如果她让梅迪纳坐下来，更多地解释前方可能有什么？毫无疑问。我完全被蒙在鼓里。
And I didn't realize how blinding that darkness was until much, much later. When I spoke to her, Medina told me she was now about the same age. Her mother had been when Medina was a small child. She's asked herself what she would have done if she had been in her mother's shoes. How would she have raised Medina? In hindsight, I believe that I was not equipped to handle that at 12 years old. How do you tell a child? This is something you're gonna have to fight for the rest of your life. Regardless, how good you are. It crushed me as an adult when I finally understood what it was occurring throughout my entire life.
直到很久很久以后，我才意识到那种黑暗是多么令人目盲。当我与她交谈时，梅迪纳告诉我，她现在的年龄大约和当年她还是个小女孩时她母亲的年龄一样。她问过自己，如果她处于母亲的位置，她会怎么做。她会如何抚养梅迪纳？事后看来，我认为我12岁时并没有能力应对这一切。你怎么能告诉一个孩子？这是你余生都必须为之抗争的东西。无论你有多优秀。当我最终明白我一生中一直在发生什么时，作为成年人的我崩溃了。
When we come back, why individuals and even entire nations can sometimes see the world through rose-colored glasses. Plus, what we gain and what we lose when we ignore discrimination. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Medina's slice was growing up, she saw examples of unfairness, but not the big picture. She could tell that boys who wanted to play basketball had an easier time doing it than girls. She noticed that people in predominantly white towns looked at her strangely. She recognized that she was sometimes held to a different standard than her peers.
当我们回来时，为什么个人甚至是整个国家有时会戴着玫瑰色眼镜看世界。另外，当我们忽视歧视时，我们得到了什么，又失去了什么。你在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。当梅迪纳·斯莱斯长大时，她看到了不公平的例子，但没有看到全貌。她能看出想打篮球的男孩比女孩更容易做到这一点。她注意到以白人为主的小镇上的人用奇怪的眼光看她。她意识到自己有时受到与同龄人不同的标准的要求。
But Medina always came up with alternate frameworks to explain what she saw and what she heard. If anything, obstacles prompted her to work harder. She allowed nothing to diminish her passion for basketball. But later in life, as an adult, this naivete became dangerous. Medina's story raises questions about the double-edged sword of knowledge when it comes to discrimination and prejudice. Knowing the ways of the world can help keep you safe,
但梅迪纳总是能想出替代的框架来解释她所看到和听到的一切。如果有的话，障碍促使她更加努力地工作。她不允许任何东西削弱她对篮球的热情。但在晚年，作为成年人，这种天真变得危险起来。梅迪纳的故事引发了人们对知识在面对歧视和偏见时作为双刃剑的疑问。了解世界的运作方式可以帮助你保持安全，
but it can also sometimes hinder you. When is knowledge useful and when is it not? Jamie Napier didn't feel she experienced discrimination when she was in college. I was the math major in college. I'd worked in computer programming and I thought that I was treated programming and I thought that I was treated, you know, like one of the team and completely fair. When Jamie became a professor, she noticed her female students that exactly the way she had felt in college. They thought gender bias was completely uninteresting. It wasn't a problem anymore. It was never going to happen to them. Jamie is now a psychologist at New York University in Abu Dhabi.
但有时它也会阻碍你。知识什么时候有用，什么时候没用？杰米·纳皮尔在大学时并不觉得她经历了歧视。我是大学里的数学专业。我从事过计算机编程，我认为我受到的对待——编程，并且我认为我受到的对待，你知道的，就像团队的一员一样，完全公平。当杰米成为一名教授时，她注意到她的女学生们有着和她当年在大学时完全一样的感受。她们认为性别偏见完全不值得关注。这不再是个问题了。这绝不会发生在她们身上。杰米现在是阿布扎比纽约大学的心理学家。
She studies how and why people arrive at their conclusions about discrimination and how these conclusions affect their well-being. She has analyzed survey results from about 20,000 people across 23 countries. She has compared objective measures of gender discrimination in each country with the extent to which people in those countries believe that there is gender discrimination. People responded on the scale from, you know, not at all a problem to a very bad problem. You might expect that in countries where objective measures pointed to greater sexism, people in those countries would say, sexism was a real problem.
她研究人们如何以及为什么得出关于歧视的结论，以及这些结论如何影响他们的福祉。她分析了来自23个国家约20,000人的调查结果。她将每个国家性别歧视的客观指标与这些国家的人们认为存在性别歧视的程度进行了比较。人们在从“完全不是问题”到“非常严重的问题”的量表上做出回应。你可能会期望，在客观指标指向更大性别歧视的国家，那里的人们会说，性别歧视是一个真正的问题。
And it's completely the opposite. It's absolutely the inverse. People in those countries would say sexism was a real problem. And it's completely the opposite. It's absolutely the inverse. The more gender inequality in a country, the more people in that country are likely to say that gender inequality is not a problem. In other words, people in Russia were more likely to think their country was a bastion of gender equality, while people in Sweden felt their nation was rife with sexism. When the opposite is true, as we know from more objective indices. In the World Economic Forum's 2020 report on the Global Gender Gap, Sweden was ranked the fourth most gender-equal country in the world. Russia was ranked 81st.
事实完全相反。这绝对是反比例的。那些国家的人们会说性别歧视是一个真正的问题。而事实恰恰相反。绝对是成反比的。一个国家的性别不平等程度越高，该国的人民就越倾向于认为性别不平等不是问题。换句话说，俄罗斯人更倾向于认为他们的国家是性别平等的堡垒，而瑞典人则觉得他们的国家充斥着性别歧视。正如我们从更客观的指数中所知，事实恰恰相反。在世界经济论坛2020年全球性别差距报告中，瑞典被评为世界上性别平等程度第四高的国家。俄罗斯排名第81位。
There's a puzzle here. Why would people believe something that isn't true? Now one explanation is straightforward. If you're a white person in a racist country, denying racism can allow you to avoid making changes to a system that works for you. If you're a man, denying sexism conveniently allows you to perpetuate patriarchal attitudes. But the interesting thing Jamie found is that in many countries, some of the people denying prejudice would those on the receiving end of it. Why would women deny gender discrimination? Why would they say gender discrimination
这里有个谜题。为什么人们会相信不真实的事情？现在，一个解释很简单。如果你是一个种族主义国家的白人，否认种族主义可以让你避免对一个对你有利的体制进行改变。如果你是一个男人，否认性别歧视可以让你轻而易举地延续父权制态度。但杰米发现有趣的是，在许多国家，一些否认偏见的人恰恰是承受偏见的一方。为什么女性会否认性别歧视？为什么女性会说性别歧视
is not a problem? And what we found is that it correlates with people's subjective well-being. So there are feelings of happiness, their feelings of life satisfaction, the more women think that gender discrimination is on a problem anymore, they'll overall be happier they are and the more satisfied with their lives they are. And we found that was especially true in places where gender inequality is a really big problem.
不是问题？我们发现这与人们的主观幸福感相关。所以她们的幸福感、生活满意度，女性越是认为性别歧视不再是个问题，她们的总体幸福感就越高，对生活的满意度也越高。我们发现这在性别不平等是一个非常严重的问题的地方尤其如此。
Jamie has looked at other groups in other contexts. In one series of studies, conducted before recent changes to US laws that used to discriminate against gay and lesbian people, Jamie looked at the perceptions LGBTQ people had about discrimination. It seemed impossible that a person who identified as a gay man or lesbian woman would say discrimination against my group is not a problem. But what we found is there was substantial amount of variance in how people answered that question. There were a lot of people saying, no, it's not that bad. Exactly as she had found with women in Russia who didn't think sexism was a problem,
杰米研究了其他背景下的其他群体。在一系列研究中，在最近美国改变歧视同性恋人群的法律之前进行的研究中，杰米研究了LGBTQ人群对歧视的看法。一个自认为是男同性恋或女同性恋的人会说“针对我们群体的歧视不是问题”，这似乎是不可能的。但我们发现，人们对该问题的回答存在相当大的差异。有很多人说，不，没那么糟。正如她在俄罗斯那些不认为性别歧视是问题的女性身上发现的那样，
Jamie found that plenty of gay and lesbian Americans did not think homophobia was a big problem. And these people did better on various measures of subjective well-being. We found that those people were also reporting better subjective well-being and in that case, actually better physical well-being. Now it's possible that members of disadvantaged groups who don't believe there is discrimination may have just gotten lucky.
杰米发现，许多同性恋美国人并不认为同性恋恐惧症是一个大问题。这些人各项主观幸福感指标表现得更好。我们发现这些人也报告了更好的主观幸福感，在这种情况下，实际上还有更好的身体健康状况。现在，不相信存在歧视的弱势群体成员可能只是运气好。
They might not have faced discrimination themselves, but Jamie tested that possibility. You're happier and healthier, regardless of whether or not you've experienced discrimination yourself. In some cases, it was actually even more strong among people who had personally been discriminated against. They were happier and healthier than their counterparts who acknowledged the discrimination against the group was an issue. If you've been victimized by an unfair world, it might seem odd that you can't see the
他们自己可能没有面临过歧视，但杰米检验了这种可能性。无论你是否亲自经历过歧视，你都会更快乐、更健康。在某些情况下，在那些个人曾遭受过歧视的人当中，这种现象甚至更为强烈。与那些承认针对该群体的歧视是一个问题的同行相比，他们更快乐、更健康。如果你是不公正世界的受害者，你看不出这种不公正，这似乎很奇怪。
unfairness. But Jamie says there could be a reason for that. It's a way for members of disadvantaged groups to legitimize the system, see the world as fair without having to sort of internalize the inequality. in a party. When Medina came up with innocent explanations for Bias directed at her, when Thai's parents were unaware of the ethnic slurs directed at them, they were spared from suffering. The same thing happens even if you are not a child or don't understand slurs in an unfamiliar language. Anyone on the receiving end of prejudice can derive comfort by looking away.
但杰米说这背后可能有原因。这是弱势群体使体制合法化的一种方式，他们认为世界是公平的，而不必将不平等内化。当梅迪纳为针对她的偏见想出无辜的解释时，当泰的父母不知道针对他们的种族贬低时，他们免受了痛苦。即使你不是小孩子或者听不懂陌生语言中的污辱，同样的事情也会发生。任何遭受偏见的人都可以通过移开视线来获得安慰。
This idea is part of a provocative theory in psychology that's known as system justification theory basically proposes that people are motivated to varying degrees depending on the situation and maybe their own disposition to see the system that they live under as fair and legitimate because seeing the alternative is really kind of taxing and distressing. Think about how devastated Ty was when he read online comments about his parents that were laced with ethnic slurs. He understood what the comments were saying and it hurt. System justification theory is not just about how victims can find it easier to look away from prejudice. Even if you are not directly harmed, it can be psychologically taxing to observe unfairness in the world. That's because it's hard to see unfairness and not ask the question,
这个观点是心理学中一个具有挑衅性的理论的一部分，被称为系统辩护理论，它基本上提出，根据情况以及可能他们自己的性格，人们在不同程度上受到激励，将他们赖以生存的体制视为公平和合法的，因为看到替代方案确实有点让人心力交瘁和痛苦。想想当泰读到网上充斥着针对他父母的种族歧视言论时他是多么崩溃。他懂那些评论在说什么，这很痛。系统辩护理论不仅关乎受害者如何能更轻松地无视偏见。即使你没有直接受害，目睹世界上的不公也会在心理上让人心力交瘁。这是因为很难看到不公却不问这样一个问题：
what should I be doing about it? When you see problems with the current system, it sort of makes you need to act on those. So this idea of wanting to see, you know, the world is fair, that people get what they deserve and deserve what they get. And that makes us feel better about things. And so there's this sort of unconscious drive to perceive the system as fair. Mm. So in other words, if I pass a homeless person
我应该为此做些什么？当你看到现有体制存在问题时，它会促使你需要对这些问题采取行动。所以这种想要看到——你知道的——世界是公平的，人们得到他们应得的，应得他们得到的。这让我们对事情感觉更好。因此存在这种无意识的驱使，去把体制感知为公平的。嗯。换句话说，如果我经过一个无家可归的人
on the street, if I tell myself, I'm responsible for this homeless person, it puts me in a difficult spot because it asks me, how much am I willing to help this homeless person? But if I tell myself, well, this homeless person is there because they made bad choices. And if they had only made better choices, they wouldn't be in the situation they're in.
在街上，如果我告诉自己，我对这个无家可归的人负有责任，这把我置于一个困难的境地，因为它质问我：我愿意花多少精力去帮助这个无家可归的人？但如果我告诉自己，这个无家可归的人沦落至此是因为他们做了糟糕的选择。如果他们当初做出更好的选择，他们就不会落得今天的地步。
In some ways, it allows me to wash my hands. Yeah, I mean, that's actually a perfect example. And we actually have work from our research team that has shown that people who are high on system justification, so we have a scale that measures it actually show less physiological reaction when you show them clips of homeless people. If we can turn a blind eye to injustice or better yet, if we can tell ourselves a story that the injustice is not injustice at all, we can feel better about the world. Our stories about the world, in other words, can serve as an unconscious defense mechanism.
在某种程度上，这让我可以洗手不管。是的，我的意思是，这其实是一个完美的例子。我们研究团队的工作实际上表明，高系统辩护得分的人——我们有一个衡量它的量表——当向他们展示无家可归者的片段时，实际上表现出更少的生理反应。如果我们能对不公正视而不见，或者更好的是，如果我们能告诉自己一个故事，说不公正根本不是不公正，我们就能对这个世界感觉更好。换句话说，我们关于世界的故事可以作为一种无意识的防御机制。
This is true not just for people who are victimized by the system, it can be true for people who benefit from it as well. So when you see inequality, you want to come up with an explanation for that that makes that inequality seem legitimate. Okay, maybe women don't like to work in science. It's not the system. It's not a system level bias. Now to be clear, this does not mean that just because you can't see prejudice in a given
这不仅适用于受体制迫害的人，对于那些从中受益的人来说也是如此。因此，当你看到不平等时，你会想出一个解释，让这种不平等看起来是合法的。好吧，也许女性就是不喜欢从事科学工作。这不是体制的问题。这不是系统层面的偏见。需要明确的是，这并不意味着仅仅因为你在特定情况下看不到偏见，
situation, that you're involved in system justification. It's entirely possible that in a particular situation, prejudice might not be the best explanation. But Jamie told me that tends to be a pattern in the way people come up with system-justifying views. A system-justifying response that you see very often is people really harping on that one example that legitimates their
你就参与了系统辩护。完全有可能在特定情况下，偏见可能不是最好的解释。但杰米告诉我，人们提出系统辩护观点的方式往往有一种模式。你经常看到的系统辩护反应是，人们紧抓着那个使他们的世界观合法化的单一例子不放，对吧？所以如果他们知道某个无家可归的人确实做了一些糟糕的人生选择或者是个糟糕的人，那个例子就会经常被提及。他们会更深刻地记住这个例子，并且往往会错误地记住其他不符合这种世界观的例子。梅迪纳在洗手间经历的事件为我们提供了一个快照，展示了歧视以及我们对歧视的感知如何塑造我们的福祉。如果梅迪纳意识到那些盯着她看的人视她为
worldview, right? So if they know of a homeless person who did make some terrible life choices or was a terrible person, that example will come up a lot. And they'll remember that example much more and they'll tend to misremember other examples that don't conform to that worldview. The incident Medina experienced in the bathroom gives us a snapshot of how discrimination and our perceptions of discrimination can shape our well-being. What would it have felt like for Medina to recognize the people staring at her saw her as
劣等人，她会有什么感觉？我把这个问题抛给了杰米。你知道的，如果她当时把这种联系联系起来，意识到他们看着她是因为她是黑人，这会影响她的表现，你知道的，这会让人痛苦。所以它最终不仅在当时拯救了她的心理健康，可能还拯救了她的宝贝或她的表现以及所有这些。正如你所看到的，这里存在着一种张力：什么对作为个人的我们有效，与什么对作为社会的我们有效，这两者之间存在张力。那些直面社会缺陷而不退缩的个人
inferior? I put the question to Jamie. You know, if she would have made that connection that they were looking at her because she was black, it would have affected her performance, you know, it would have been distressing. So it ended up not only kind of saving her mental health in the moment, but probably also her baby or her performance and all of that. As you can see, there is a tension here between what works for us as individuals and what works for us as a society. Individuals who look unflinchingly at the failings of their
可能会付出沉重的个人代价。如果你移开视线，你可以免受这些。但移开视线并非没有代价。当许多人都移开视线时，偏见就会恶化。我们往往发现的一点是，对个人好的东西可能对社会并不好。所以如果你认为性别歧视不是问题，你就不会参与集体行动，你就不会去关注帮助你的其他女性同事诸如此类的事情，
societies can pay a terrible personal price. You are spared that if you look away. But looking away is not cost-free. When lots of people look away, prejudice, festers. One of the things that we tend to find are what might be good for the individual is probably not good for societies. So if you think to gender discrimination is not a problem, you're not going to engage in collective action, you're not going to be attuned to helping your other female colleagues, that kind of thing,
这会让性别不平等长期存在下去。与此同时，很难去批评那些生活在一个选择很少、改变体制的选项极其有限的威逼利诱国家中的某些个人，要求某人持有能够定期向他们揭示体制是多么不公平、他们是多么脆弱的观点。你也可以从个人的角度理解为什么这会非常痛苦和难以做到。这绝对是真的，所以，是的，这肯定具有某种适应性功能。但并非所有人都生活在威权政体中。
and it's going to allow the gender inequality to perpetuate. At the same time, it's hard to feel critical of some of the individuals who are living in an authoritarian country with very few options that change the system, and asking someone to hold views that reveal to them on a regular basis how unfair the system is, how vulnerable they are. You can also see from an individual's point of view why that would be really painful and difficult to do. That's absolutely true and so yeah, there is an adaptive function to this for sure. But not everyone lives in authoritarian regimes.
我们在美国国内也发现了这些影响。与面临针对自身群体的歧视时会予以否认的其他弱势群体相比，美国的女性更有可能否认性别歧视。如果对世界保持清醒的认识会带来痛苦和失望，这是否意味着我们在要求人们在个人心理健康和社会福祉之间做出选择？这是一个如此艰难的问题。显然，我们不希望任何人感到不高兴或痛苦，但与此同时，打击不平等的第一步是承认它。
And we find these effects within the United States. Women in the US are much more likely to deny gender discrimination than you would see compared to other disadvantaged groups denying discrimination against their own groups. If being clear-eyed about the world produces hurt and disappointment, does this mean we are asking people to choose between personal mental well-being and societal well-being? It's such a hard question. Obviously we don't want anyone to be unhappy or are distressed but at the same time the first step in fighting inequality is to recognize it.
认真对待这个等式的两端是很重要的。光是说人们应该选择艰难的道路因为这对社会有益是不够的。有时当你筋疲力尽、不堪重负时，你根本不想战斗。你想举手投降、扔掉毛巾。并不是说，你知道的，我们希望人们整天走来走去，看到世界上的所有问题，因为那也无济于事。我们需要人们有足够的动力去抗击不平等。所以当你想到诸如“MeToo”运动之类的事情时，我的意思是这些女性认识到她们受到了不公的对待，
It's important to take seriously both ends of this equation. It's not enough to say people should choose the hard path because that's good for society. Sometimes when you're exhausted and overwhelmed, you don't feel like fighting. You want to throw up your hands and throw in the towel. And it's not that, you know, we want people to walk around all the times, seeing all the problems in the world, because that's not going to help either. We need people to feel motivated enough to fight inequality. So when you think about things like the Me Too movement, I mean these women recognize that they were treated unfairly,
认真对待这个等式的两端是很重要的。光是说人们应该选择艰难的道路是因为这对社会有好处是不够的。有时当你精疲力竭、不知所措时，你根本不想去抗争。你想放弃并举手投降。这并不是说，你知道的，我们希望人们无时无刻不在四处走动、看到世上所有的问题，因为那也帮不上忙。我们需要人们有足够的动力去抗击不平等。所以当你想到类似“我也是”运动（Me Too）这样的事情时，我是说这些女性意识到她们受到了不公正的对待，
but they also had the strength and the belief in themselves and the confidence to be like, well, that wasn't right and to fight it. I'm sure that their subjective well-being took a hit while they were having to go through that process. But what you can hope is that to the extent that they have success, that they can regain that self-esteem because they are restoring justice in the right way. Not by denying the injustice, but actually by making things more fair in reality. When we come back,
但她们也拥有力量、对自己的信念以及自信，去表现得像——嗯，那是不对的——并与之抗争。我敢肯定，在她们经历这个过程时，她们的主观幸福感受到了打击。但你可以希望的是，在她们取得成功的范围内，她们可以重新获得自尊，因为她们正在以正确的方式恢复正义。不是通过否认不公正，而是通过在现实中让事情变得更加公平。当我们回来时，
is there a way to get the benefits of knowledge while minimizing its costs? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Jamie Napier has found that people who experience discrimination can personally benefit from putting on blinders. You can feel better about the world and how the world treats you if you ignore the hurtful things the world does to you. But what happens when prejudice is so blatant, so obvious, and so common, that looking away is not an option.
有没有一种方法既能获得知识的好处，又能将其成本降到最低？你在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。心理学家杰米·纳皮尔发现，经历过歧视的人可以通过戴上眼罩来获得个人好处。如果你忽视世界对你做的那些伤人的事，你对这个世界以及世界对待你的方式就会感觉更好。但当偏见如此公然、如此明显、如此普遍，以至于移开视线不再是一种选择时，会发生什么呢？
that looking away is not an option. Clint Smith, a poet and staff writer at the Atlantic, struggled with his very question. Clint is black. In 2015, he decided to write a letter to his son. Son, I want to tell you how difficult it is to tell someone they're both beautiful and endangered. So worthy of life yet so despised for living. I do not intend to scare you.
以至于移开视线不再是一种选择。克林特·史密斯，一位诗人兼《大西洋月刊》特约撰稿人，一直在与这个极其深刻的问题做斗争。克林特是黑人。2015年，他决定给他的儿子写一封信。儿子，我想告诉你，告诉一个人他既美丽又处于危险之中是多么困难。如此值得活着却又因活着而饱受鄙视。我无意吓唬你。
Clint did not have a son. He was writing this letter to the child he imagined he would have one day. My father, your grandfather, taught me how to follow a certain set of rules before I even knew their purpose. He told me that these rules would not apply to everyone, that they would not even apply to all my own friends, but they were rules to abide by nonetheless. nonetheless. Clint felt the need to tell his future son what it would be like to grow up as a black boy in the United States. My hope is that it would instill with him a sense of how the world might see him, but also to remind him that he should not, in his interior, feel defined by that, or should not feel predetermined by that.
克林特当时并没有儿子。他是在给想象中将来有一天会有的孩子写这封信。我的父亲，也就是你的爷爷，在我甚至不知道其目的之前，就教会了我如何遵守一套特定的规则。他告诉我，这些规则并不适用于所有人，甚至不适用于我所有的朋友，但它们依然是必须遵守的规则。尽管如此。克林特觉得有必要告诉他未来的儿子，作为美国的黑人男孩长大成人会是什么样子。我的希望是，这能在他的心中灌输一种世界可能会如何看待他的意识，同时也提醒他，在他的内心深处，他不应该被那个所定义，或者不应该被那个预先决定。
Clint was not always someone who would write a letter like this. In fact, of anything, he had things in common with the people Jamie Napier has studied, the people who see prejudice and want to look away. Clinton's understanding of how race affected his life involved a complex journey. Before he wrote the letter, Clinton had been a high school English teacher in Maryland. Most of the students lived in poor communities, most were black or brown. Clint had a clear vision of what he wanted the kids to get out of the classroom.
克林特并非一向都是个会写这种信的人。事实上，如果说有什么的话，他和杰米·纳皮尔研究过的人——那些看到偏见却想把视线移开的人——有着共同点。克林特对种族如何影响他人生的理解经历了一段复杂的旅程。在这封信写成之前，克林特曾是马里兰州的一名高中英语老师。大多数学生都住在贫困社区，大多数是黑人或棕色人种。克林特对孩子们想从课堂上得到什么有着清晰的愿景。
I had this sense that I was going to make my classroom a sanctuary in a sort of island that was protected from so much of what my students experienced outside of the classroom that was, you know, it didn't matter what was going on at home, it didn't matter what was going on outside of these four walls. My classroom could be a place where we would lose ourselves in literature. Where we wouldn't have to think about the difficulties we were experiencing at home or the violence that might be taking place on the streets
我当时有一种感觉，我要把我的教室变成一个避难所，一个免受我的学生在课堂外经历的那么多事情影响的某种岛屿，你知道的，不管家里发生了什么，不管在这四堵墙之外发生了什么都不重要。我的教室可以成为一个让我们沉浸在文学中的地方。在那里，我们不必去想我们在家里经历的困难，或者街头可能正在发生的暴力，
or the lack of job opportunities that may exist in the community or whatever, whatever the case may be. My hope was that as literature has done for me and as it does for so many, that it can transport us to a place where it gives us a sense of escape. to a place where it gives us a sense of escape. A sense of escape. Clint was drawn to books that allowed his students to leave their everyday difficulties behind, to look away from their lives. A lot of what I tried to bring into my classroom
或者社区中可能存在的就业机会匮乏，或者无论什么情况。我的希望是，正如文学为我所做的那样，正如它为许多人所做的那样，它能够把我们带到一个地方，给我们一种逃离的感觉。带到一个地方，给我们一种逃离的感觉。一种逃离的感觉。克林特被那些能让他的学生抛开日常困难、将视线从生活中移开的书籍所吸引。我试图带进课堂的很多东西
were fantasy books or books around magical realism or books that quite literally would take you out of this world that we're about people who were from different or alternative realities with Shakespeare. Friends, Romans, Julius Caesar, Contramen, Nend meorias, what women, I believe a leaf of grass is no less than a journey work of the stars. I think I sort of was running away from any type of writing or reading or discussion that might connect to specifically to the incidents that my young students were experiencing outside of the classroom.
阅读奇幻小说、魔幻现实主义作品，或者那些能真正带你脱离这个世界的书籍，那些关于来自不同或替代现实的人的书籍，比如莎士比亚的作品。“朋友们、罗马人、尤利乌斯·恺萨……”以及各种诗篇。我深信，一把草叶绝不亚于群星的杰作。我想我当时是在逃避任何可能直接与我年轻的学生们在教室外所经历的事件相联系的写作、阅读或讨论。
Often these attempts fell short. There was so much going on in the lives of the students that trying to keep them focused on Walt Whitman was like trying to keep dry in the middle of a hurricane. Finally, at one point, it no longer became possible to keep the outside world at bay. There was a drive-by student in which one of our students was killed. And I remember the next day our students came to school and people were distressed and distraught and overwhelmed with sadness at the loss of this young man's life. But there was also with some students this sense of that this was an I think that they expected to happen in some ways and I remember talking to one of my students and them saying You know, Mr. Smith. This is just how it is here like this is just what black people do and this was a young black student who was saying this and I remember feeling so
通常这些尝试都收效甚微。学生们的生活中发生了太多事情，试图让他们专注于沃尔特·惠特曼，就像在飓风中心试图保持干爽一样困难。最后，在某个时刻，将外部世界隔绝在外变得不再可能。发生了一起车内枪击事件，我们的一名学生丧生了。我记得第二天我们的学生来到学校，人们都感到痛心、沮丧，并为这个年轻生命的消逝感到极度悲伤。但同时，一些学生也流露出一种情绪，他们觉得在某种程度上这是意料之中的事。我记得曾和我的一个学生交谈过，他说：“你知道，史密斯先生，这里的事情就是这样，黑人就是这样。”这是一个年轻的黑人学生说的，我记得当时我感到……
devastated and heartbroken by that because this young person had apparently been told that the reason there is a 16 or 17 year old kid would be shot on their front porch or the reason that the communities they live in are saturated with poverty that is somehow a reflection of black people rather than things that have been done to black people to create those social conditions. And what did you tell the student when he said, this is just the way things are? What, how did you respond?
对此感到极其沮丧和心碎，因为这个年轻人显然被灌输了这样一种观念：一个16或17岁的孩子在自家门廊被枪杀的原因，或者他们生活的社区充斥着贫困的原因，在某种程度上是对黑人群体本身的一种反映，而不是那些强加给黑人群体、从而造成这些社会状况的事情。当那个学生说“事情就是这样”时，你是怎么对他说？你当时是怎么回应的？
In that moment, I don't think I responded in the way that I would have wanted to, in that moment, I think I just said, that's not true. And I think I said, it's time to get to class because the bill was ringing. And I wish, you know, I wish now that I had spent more time that I'd say it's okay for me to be a few minutes late to class. It's okay for him to be a few minutes late to class. We need to really impact this. for him to be a few minutes late to class, we need to really unpack this.
在那一刻，我觉得我的回应并不是我事后所希望的那样。那一刻，我想我只是说：“这不是真的。”然后我想我说过：“该去上课了，”因为下课铃响了。现在回想起来，我真希望当时能多花一点时间，对他们说我迟到几分钟没关系，他迟到几分钟也没关系，我们真的需要好好剖析这件事。为了让他迟到几分钟，我们真的需要好好剖析这件事。
In the aftermath of this conversation, Clint questioned his entire philosophy of teaching. I think I recognized in many ways in that moment that was doing a disservice to my students, that I want to have in my classroom each day, is not going to somehow erase the experiences they have when they go home. And this is not to say that like my students' lives were saturated and an undeniable spiral of trauma, but it is to say that many of them did experience trauma and violence and poverty. So what that moment did was help me realize that I could no longer pretend as if the things happening outside of school didn't matter inside of school. Clinton experiences growing up that mirrored that of his own students. And like his students, he found he did not possess a vocabulary to respond when white
在那次对话之后，克林特开始质疑他整套的教学理念。我想我在那一刻深刻地认识到，我一直在对我的学生做一件很不公平的事。我每天想在课堂上呈现的内容，并不能神奇地抹去他们回家后所经历的现实。这并不是说我的学生的生活充满了一种不可否认的痛苦漩涡，而是说他们中的确有许多人经历过创伤、暴力和贫困。所以那一刻发生的事情帮助我意识到，我不能再假装学校外面发生的事情在学校内部就不重要了。克林特在成长过程中也有过与他的学生相似的经历。和他的学生一样，当白人朋友提起诸如黑人杀害黑人这类问题时，他发现自己没有词汇去回应。
friends brought up issues such as black on black violence. I didn't have the toolkit to pull from in the way that I do now. I couldn't then say, per the latest FBI Bureau of Justice statistics, more than 80% of white people are killed by the white people, but no one ever is out here talking about white on white crime, because part of what we know is the nature of housing segregation in communities across the United States over the course of several decades has made it so that people
我当时没有像现在这样现成的工具箱可以调用。我当时无法说：“根据最新的联邦调查局司法统计局数据，80%以上的白人是被白人杀害的，但从来没有人在这里谈论白人杀害白人的犯罪问题。”因为我们所知道的部分原因是，几十年来美国各地社区的住房隔离性质，使得……
of certain demographics live in proximity to people of that same demographic. I didn't know how to talk about the fact that, you know, black people protest against intra-community violence within our community all of the time. Church groups are doing this work. They're stopped the violence marches in every city across the country. Clint's high school students experienced something similar. They were well aware of the stereotypes against people like them,
特定人口统计特征的人倾向于和具有相同特征的人居住在临近区域。我当时不知道该如何谈论这样一件事：黑人其实一直在抗议我们社区内部的暴力行为。教会组织一直在做这项工作。全国各地的每个城市都有“制止暴力”的游行。克林特的高中学生也经历过类似的事情。他们非常清楚针对他们这类人的刻板印象，
but didn't have the information they needed to push back against stereotypes. Clint decided to change this. I think about how important it is to give young people the language so that they are not feeling a sense of sort of paralysis, a sort of emotional paralysis in the way that I felt. He decided to come up with an intellectual toolkit.
却没有掌握反击这些刻板印象所需的必要信息。克林特决定改变这种状况。我意识到赋予年轻人话语权是多么重要，这样他们就不会像我当年那样，感受到一种无力感，一种情感上的瘫痪。他决定建立一个知识工具箱。
Clint had used the same toolkit while volunteering in a Washington, DC jail. One of his students there had read the book, The Color of the Law. The book follows the history of housing segregation in the United States. And how it is impacted black people, and also how it is created intergenerational white wealth in ways that are reflective not of anyone's hard work, but instead are reflective of opportunities
克林特在华盛顿特区的一所监狱做志愿者时，也使用过这套工具箱。他的一名学生读过《法律的颜色》这本书。该书探讨了美国住房隔离的历史，以及它是如何影响黑人同胞的，又是如何以一种并不反映任何人努力工作、而是反映白人美国人所获得的机遇的方式，创造了代际白人财富。
that were given to white Americans that simply were not given to black Americans, whether it be through the GI bill, the different facets of the New Deal or other ways, you know, in the early 20th century. I remember us having a conversation about before class. I remember him saying, nobody ever taught me this. Like, nobody ever told me anything about this. The book transformed the way the young man understood his community, and why someone like him had ended up in jail. It's not to absolve him of what he did. It is not to say that he doesn't have free will or agency over the sorts of decisions that he makes, but it is to help him and to help us better understand the context in which free will and agency are able to manifest themselves and to better understand that I didn't find
而这些机遇并没有给予黑人美国人，无论通过《退伍军人权利法案》、新政的各个方面还是20世纪初的其他途径。我记得我们在上课前讨论过这件事。我记得他说：“从来没有人教过我这些。从来没有人跟我说过这些。”这本书改变了这个年轻人对他的社区的理解，也改变了他为什么会落入囹圄的理解。这并不是为了免除他所犯罪行的责任，也不是说他对所做的决定没有自由意志或自主权，而是为了帮助他以及我们更好地理解自由意志和自主权得以展现的语境，并更好地理解我之所以陷入犯罪，
myself entangled in crime simply because I'm a bad person. I found myself entangled in this world because I was born into a community that for decades had been plundered and decimated by decisions that my municipal, state, and federal government had been making. And that that is part of the reason why my neighborhood and my community and my city looked the way that they do. That book was transformative for him. It was transformative for him in understanding his community. It book was transformative for him. It was transformative for him in understanding his community, and it was also transformative for him in understanding himself and his relationship to the world.
并非仅仅因为我是一个坏人。我之所以陷入这个世界，是因为我出生在一个几十年来一直遭到市政府、州政府和联邦政府制定的政策掠夺和摧残的社区。这也是我的街区、我的社区和我的城市呈现出目前这种面貌的部分原因。那本书对他是具有变革意义的。它不仅改变了他对社区的理解，也改变了他对自身以及自己与世界关系的理解。
Clint told me he's struggled with the double ed sword of knowledge. When I spoke with him, we talked about the viral video that set off nationwide protests in 2020. I can't breathe, I can't breathe. The murder of George Floyd. I mean, I still haven't watched the George Floyd recording, you know, all these months later. I don't know how beneficial it would be for me to watch another person, you know, be killed on camera.
克林特告诉我，他一直在与知识的双刃剑作斗争。我和他交谈时，我们谈到了2020年引发全国抗议的那个广为流传的视频。“我不能呼吸了，我不能呼吸了。”乔治·弗洛伊德之死。我的意思是，时隔这么多个月，我仍然没有看过乔治·弗洛伊德遇害的录像。我不知道看着另一个人在镜头前被杀害，对我会产生多少真正的好处。
I've seen it happen so many times. I don't think that watching it happen would do anything other than cause me to sort of fall into a spiral of despair. I'm so struck by what you're saying because of course this seems completely understandable to me that at a certain point you just feel I can't take anymore and I just listening to it or watching it is going to prompt me to despair and in fact to inaction. I want to talk about what this line is between these two kinds of knowledge. You go to a prison and you tell people in prison, I want to give you a new understanding of why it is you're in prison. You're not just in prison because of what you did and the fact
我看到这种事发生得太多次了。除了让我陷入绝望的漩涡之外，看它发生不会起到任何其他作用。你所说的话深深触动了我，因为这对我来说完全可以理解：在某个特定时刻，你会觉得再也无法承受了，仅仅是听着或看着它，都会促使我走向绝望，甚至导致无所作为。我想谈谈这两种知识之间的界限在哪里。你去监狱告诉监狱里的人：“我想让你们对你们为什么入狱有新的理解。你们入狱不仅仅是因为你们做的事，以及……”
that the cops caught you and you had a trial and you end up here. But it's in fact a deeper, larger story and understanding that deeper, larger story, that history, that structure, that context feels empowering. It feels empowering as I'm hearing you tell the story to sort of say, yes, it helps me understand the bigger picture of why it is that I'm here. And maybe there's something I can do about the larger story. And then you have this other kind of knowledge, which is also knowledge, which is says, let me watch how George Floyd was killed. Let me watch the next video and the next video and the next video and each of them is a piece
警察抓了你们、经过审判后你们最终来到这里。事实上，这背后是一个更深、更大的故事。理解这个更深、更大的故事——那种历史、那种结构、那种语境——会让人感到充满力量。当我听你讲述这个故事时，它让人感到充满力量，仿佛在说：“是的，它帮助我理解了我为什么会到这里的宏观图景，也许对于这个更大的故事，我还能做些什么。”然后你拥有了另一种知识，它同样也是知识，那就是：“让我看看乔治·弗洛伊德是怎么被杀害的。让我看下一个视频，再看下一个，再下一个，每一个都是……”
of knowledge. But collectively, the effect that it has on you is not empowering, but in fact the opposite. Why do you think that is? The same thing, knowing something, can produce these effects that are so diametrically opposing to one another? My initial sense is that there's a threshold, if you will, sort of emotional and psychological threshold, that once you cross, it is not helpful
知识碎片。但总体而言，它对你产生的影响不是赋予力量，而恰恰相反。你认为这是为什么呢？同样的“知晓”某事，怎么会产生如此截然相反的效果？我最初的感觉是，这里存在一个阈值，可以说是情感和心理上的阈值。一旦你跨过了这个阈值，继续让自己暴露在如此深沉且充满密室感的暴力画面中，就再也没有益处了，
in many ways, it is unhelpful, to continue to expose yourself to images of violence that feel so profound in the intimate. That feel is if they could be you, the feel is if you might be watching yourself or your son or your daughter or your friend or the people you love. It's a sort of emotional oversaturation and that oversaturation can turn into a sort of paralysis. That is something that's very different than this sort of intellectual toolkit
反而有害。那种感觉仿佛受害者就是你自己，仿佛你看到的是自己、你的儿子、你的女儿、你的朋友或者你爱的人。这是一种情感上的过度饱和，而这种过度饱和会演变成一种瘫痪状态。这与人们通过阅读历史、阅读政策、阅读社会学以及阅读那些经历过这些事情的人的故事所获得的知识工具箱，有着本质上的不同。
that one can obtain from reading history, from reading policy, from reading sociology, from reading the stories of those who have experienced these things. And you know, to be clear, they can there can also be a sort of oversaturation with that. You know, if the only thing that one ever reads is all of the different ways that America and the world have oppressed black people, that too can reach a point of oversaturation. That too can destabilize you. As much as I read about incarceration,
而且需要明确的是，对于后者同样也可能存在过度饱和。你知道，如果一个人唯一阅读的内容，就是美国和世界压迫黑人的各种不同方式，那也可能会达到过度饱和的程度。那同样会动摇你的心智。尽管我阅读了大量关于监禁、
about slavery, as much as I read about Jim Crow, it is also important for me to watch Netflix shows of black people who are dancing and who are singing and who are following dreams of becoming a superhero, right? All of those are important because if you only ever consume the despair, then you are more likely to embody and feel that sense of despair rather than the fullness of what it means to be human. Hmm. I'm also wondering, Clint, as you're talking,
关于奴隶制的资料，阅读了大量关于吉姆·克劳法的文章，但对我来说，观看Netflix上那些黑人跳舞、唱歌以及追逐超级英雄梦想的节目同样重要，对吧？所有这些都很重要，因为如果你只摄入绝望，那么你更倾向于体现和感受到那种绝望感，而不是去体验作为一个完整的人的丰富内涵。嗯。克林特，当你在说话时，我也在想，
and here, let me run an idea by you, it's part of the distinction about the difference between the watt and the why. It's obviously important to know about the watt. It's important to know what happened. It's important to know what happened. It's important to know what happened to George Floyd. It's important to know what happened with, you know, what's happening in the news with, you know, the Breonna Taylor case. But it's also the case that at a certain point, the what actually becomes so repetitive that
在这里，让我向你抛出一个想法，这涉及到“是什么”与“为什么”之间的区别的一部分。了解“是什么”显然很重要。了解发生了什么很重要。了解乔治·弗洛伊德身上发生了什么很重要。了解新闻中布伦娜·泰勒案的情况发生了什么也很重要。但同样的情况是，在某个时刻，“是什么”实际上变得如此重复，
it actually is not opening our minds. It actually has this effect of accretion where it just feels like you're being buried under this pile of stones. But the why, and I hear you tell the story about what you did in the classroom or what you did in the prison, to me that knowledge is less about the what, and it's more about the why. Is it possible that there's a difference between those two things? Absolutely. No, I think that that is a huge part of it.
以至于它并没有在开拓我们的思维。它实际上产生了一种积累效应，让你感觉自己像是被埋在了一堆石头底下。但是“为什么”——我听你讲述你在教室或监狱里所做的事情——在我看来，这种知识较少关于“是什么”，而更多关于“为什么”。这两者之间是否存在差异呢？绝对有。不，我认为这是其中极其重要的一部分。
It's just so important. And it's so essential because you don't, you can no longer think of yourself as a static human being that who you are is who you will always be, and that who you are was who you were destined to be because of what you look like, or because of the community you were born into. And you're able to contextualize it for yourself in a way that, again, I just think is really, really liberating and has the potential to be emancipatory and transformative for for how a person sees themselves in the world and moves throughout it. Too often we confuse knowledge with information. It's certainly important to know what has happened to learn facts.
这太重要了。这是绝对关键的，因为你不能再把自己看作一个一成不变的人，认为你是谁就永远是谁，认为由于你的外表或你出生的社区，你注定要成为什么样的人。你能够以一种对自己有益的方式将其置于语境中，再次强调，我认为这真的非常具有解放意义，并且有可能对一个人如何看待自己在世界上的地位以及如何在其中前行，产生革命性和变革性的影响。我们常常把知识与信息混淆。了解发生了什么以获取事实当然很重要。
But on their own, facts can sometimes deaden us or leave us feeling hopeless. Far from motivating us to change, they can spur us toward inaction. The News Media often shows us the what without explaining the why. As we watch video after disturbing video or scroll past tweet after disturbing tweet, we might think we are educating ourselves. But all too often, we are really just painting ourselves into a corner of despair. Clint's letter to a son made clear that the point of knowledge is action, transformation. Do not for a moment think you cannot change what exists. This world is a social construction.
但仅凭事实有时会让我们感到麻木或绝望。它们非但不能激励我们去改变，反而会促使我们走向无所作为。新闻媒体经常向我们展示“是什么”，却不解释“为什么”。当我们观看一个又一个令人不安的视频，或者刷过一个又一个令人不安的推文时，我们可能以为自己在教育自己。但很多时候，我们其实只是把自己逼入了绝望的死胡同。克林特写给儿子的信明确指出，知识的意义在于行动与变革。不要有一刻认为你无法改变现存的一切。这个世界是一个社会建构。
It can be reconstructed. This world was built. It can be rebuilt. Use everything that you accrue to reimagine the world. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
它是可以被重新建构的。这个世界是被建造出来的。它是可以被重建的。利用你所积累的一切去重新构想这个世界。“Hidden Brain”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to former Hidden Brain producer Raina Cohen, who played an important role in today's show. We also want to thank the NPR Library for their research support and the WNBA for providing us with archival footage. Our runs on Hero today is Alison Craiglow, the executive producer of the Frekenomics Radio Network. Alison has been a vital partner in the launch of our new production company, offering insights on everything from podcast advertising to hiring. Alison, we know how precious your time is. Thank you for being so generous with your advice and your help. For more hidden brain, you can subscribe to our newsletter at news.hiddenbrain.org.
我是“Hidden Brain”的执行主编。本周特别感谢前“Hidden Brain”制片人雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen），她在今天的节目中发挥了重要作用。我们还要感谢NPR图书馆提供的研究支持，以及WNBA为我们提供的档案素材。我们今天的赞助商是 Alison Craiglow，她是“Freakonomics Radio Network”的执行制片人。Alison 一直是我们新制作公司成立的重要合作伙伴，在从播客广告到招聘的各个方面都提供了真知灼见。Alison，我们深知你的时间有多宝贵。非常感谢你如此慷慨地给予我们建议和帮助。欲了解更多“Hidden Brain”的内容，您可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 订阅我们的简报。
If you'd like to support our show, please go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想支持我们的节目，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 并点击“支持”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），下周见。目前本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。